things are looking up for the u.s.
polish alliance Trump welcomed his
guests polish president Andrea Duda with
an f-35 fly over the polls want to
purchase more than 30 of the u.s. made
fighter jets a deal like that gets a
reward over a fireplace chat Trump
suggested a thousand additional troops
could be relocated from Germany to
Poland we have 52,000 troops in Germany
and Germany is not living up to what
they're supposed to be doing with
respect to NATO and Poland is have to
congratulate you thank you very much
Poland is seeking more security from the
u.s. to quell its concerns about Russian
activity as well as military equipment
the two leaders signed a multi-billion
dollar deal for the sale of US liquefied
gas to Poland for duda the international
visit is also about national politics
Poland will hold parliamentary elections
later this year shortly before the vote
Duda wants Trump to make an appearance
to take part in world war ii
commemorations mr. president we all hope
that you'll visit us in Poland in
September when we mark the anniversary
of the invasion by Nazi Germany Oleg Lee
is Genaro gave our initiative extra
Trump says he'll consider the invitation
for what would be his second official
visit to Poland let's get more on the
story now with our political
correspondent Thomas Farrow he's
standing by for us hi Thomas
we heard Donald Trump again lashing out
at Germany over its military spending
what did you make of his comments
well the key word to me is again it is
not necessarily new what Trump has
indicated he uses every possible chance
to lash out at Germany's defense
spending he says Germany hasn't been
spending enough on the common defense he
has also criticized Germany once again
on North stream Donald Trump is
particularly critical of Germany's
planned nordstrom through projects
because he believed Germany would be
hostage to Russian interest so these are
not necessarily new words from
Donald Trump but they do reveal once
again the difficult situation that the
transatlantic relationship is facing you
mentioned North stream that's the
pipeline that brings gas from Russia to
Germany and as you said Donald Trump has
some particularly strong words to say
there let's listen to what he said I
mean Germany made a decision to buy a
tremendous percentage of their energy
from Russia Germany whether they should
be doing that or not they're the ones
that have the power to block it they
shouldn't buy it or if they want to they
can but that's really a decision of
Germany I'm not saying that I would be
in favor I think the German people
aren't very happy about it because it
really makes Germany a hostage of Russia
if things ever happen okay Thomas these
comments are not new from the US
president but still should the German
government be worried about them and
warnings of a potential sanctions as
well I think in a way they are worried
there are political implications here
there are economic implications here as
well so obviously the German government
and German authorities in general are
looking at these statements very
carefully but when we look at Donald
Trump and his comments on Nordstrom too
we have to also understand that there
are economic interests for the u.s. at
hand Donald Trump posted about the u.s.
becoming an extremely important energy
supplier and in fact the u.s. signed a
contract with Poland when it comes to
LNG to liquefy national natural gas so
it's not only about politics and his
criticism of Germany and Russia it is
also very much about the US economic
interest as well he assuming our
political correspondent Thomas Sparrow
reporting for us good to talk to you
Thomas